in her first two years at the Federal
Trade Commission chair Lena Khan has
already taken on the biggest Tech Titans
in the world her beef is with the
biggest company and she's lost big to
some of them I'm certainly not somebody
who thinks that success is marked by a
hundred percent court record that
strategy has made her a lightning rod
for controversy and criticism this
raises the question Sher Khan are you
losing on purpose so what drives her to
take on the toughest fights and what
happens if she doesn't win and I trust
lawyers say that this is as aggressive
as they've seen the FTC in a very long
time over the last century we've seen
time and time again that when we have
robust antitrust enforcement in robust
competition that really sets us up best
to have the strongest most thriving
economy in 2021 the year Khan was sworn
in as chair the FTC issued 42 letters of
investigation over M A that's almost
twice the amount in 2020 and the highest
in more than a decade when the FTC does
investigations they type their own
resources and they sort of tie a deal in
knots for as long as a year and
investigating more deals can slow down
the merger Market overall more important
is the chilling effect that they're
having on M A activity in general
Stoller is a friend and former co-worker
of Khan they're trying to address
activities that are Central to coercive
behavior in the economy right now by
challenging vertical mergers
by big companies dominant infrastructure
players and it's not just the number of
mergers the FTC investigates it's also
the type of company the agency is
scrutinizing we are also entirely
outgunned especially when we are up
against some of the most formidable and
wealthiest and most powerful companies
in America but that hasn't stopped Khan
from taking on companies like meta or
Microsoft Lena's supporters do think
that she's bringing the cases that the
government was too chicken in the past
to bring but those big shots haven't
necessarily panned out in February the
FTC lost its case to block meta from
acquiring virtual reality company within
and in early July a federal judge sided
with Microsoft after the agency sued to
block its merger with gaming company
Activision the FTC appealed and the
court rejected the agency's request to
block the deal in the meantime in a
statement meta said that the deal would
bring pro-competitive benefits to the
ecosystem Microsoft declined to comment
despite the losses Khan has said it's
important to take those cases to court
as public enforcers we have a special
obligation to be bringing the hard cases
because if you don't try the message
that sends out to the world is that the
enforcers don't think there's a problem
in the market still there's a risk in
losing too much it creates bad precedent
for you and and perhaps even Wall Street
and companies start to kind of tune you
out and think it's worth fighting you
because you you're not winning lawyers
I've spoken to they say maybe the FTC
should take a step back and think more
deeply about the kinds of deals that
they want to bring that will make the
points that Lena's trying to make in a
statement the agency said that in the
last year and a half the FTC has had 20
wins including several mergers that were
abandoned following FTC scrutiny the
cases that cons FTC has brought are not
always straightforward Microsoft and
Activision aren't direct competitors so
the agency needed the court to buy into
its prediction that the merger could
hurt competition in the future the
courts have had mixed responses to that
legal Theory Linda says over the last 30
odd years that the law came to put too
much focus on What's called the consumer
welfare standard which is measuring harm
from deals or from practices measuring
that in consumer prices or or like
Supply output Lena sort of disavows this
consumer welfare standard is really the
purpose of the antitrust laws what Lena
Khan is doing is to put competition at
the center of antitrust policy again and
to say actually it's about this this is
this law is about whether you can let
people into the market or not to compete
this approach is part of what got con to
the FTC the youngest FTC chair in
history she'd already made a name for
herself by the time she was appointed
after graduating from college Khan
worked at a think tank where she looked
at corporate consolidation it became
clear pretty quickly that there had been
a pretty steady trend of consolidation
across the board and in 2017 she
published an article titled Amazon's
Anti-Trust Paradox when she was still in
law school that paper reimagines the
thrust of the antitrust laws she wants
to think about antitrust enforcement and
competitive harm in a much broader way
she essentially said the way that we do
business in America is essentially
should be illegal Amazon declined to
comment that paper made her an
Anti-Trust celebrity she's a symbol of
you know a new approach to addressing
Monopoly power she has come to
prominence at a certain moment when
technology plays a huge huge role in our
lives and that's not going to change in
the future it's only going to get bigger
when President Biden came into office he
made antitrust a big part of his agenda
I'm a capitalist but capitalism without
competition is not capitalism
capitalism without competition is
exploitation when he made her chair it
was an indication of of policy and that
was a surprise to me and I think it was
a surprise to a lot of people President
Biden thinks we have a monopoly crisis
and that our Monopoly crisis is a
serious and core political economy issue
that he wants to address in and as part
of his presidency but Khan's appointment
was met with calls for her to recuse
herself from cases involving companies
she'd criticized in the past Facebook is
seeking the recusal of the FTC chair
Lena Khan I have to tell you that
Amazon's right when they say that
they're entitled to impartial
Commissioners it's not a surprise that
companies are going to throw everything
that they have at the wall to see what
sticks she didn't recuse herself from
The Meta within case despite an Ethics
officer's recommendation prompting
blowback there was no violation under
the ethics laws because I have not a
penny in Financial stock Khan is under
investigation by three republican-led
house committees for her leadership at
the FTC the agency declined to comment
but criticism has come from within the
agency too Republican commissioner
Christine Wilson resigned in early 2023
accusing Khan of an abuse of power the
commission which is usually bipartisan
is now solely Democratic in a February
statement Khan and the other
Commissioners said that while they often
disagreed with Wilson they respect her
Devotion to her beliefs Khan has also
faced employee discontent Lena Khan came
in from the start and said that the FTC
had done a lot of things wrong while
that was appealing to her supporters it
was probably alienating to some of her
staff and perhaps also to
other former Commissioners or other
former chairs we are fortunate to have
extremely talented staff at the FTC of
course we work hard to make sure that
the FTC remains a great place to work
but despite criticism and skepticism
around her strategy Khan says she isn't
going anywhere my term goes until
through 2024 and I fully intend to
continue serving including drafting
aggressive new guidelines with the
justice department on how the agency
will investigate new mergers it doesn't
seem like the FTC has a lot of time to
change its strategy so Lena Khan has a
relatively short window to accomplish as
much as she can
foreign